Not every movie needs a twist ending to drive
its point home, or even tries to stun audiences
before they leave the theatre.
But just because a movie lacks a jaw-dropping
twist, it doesn't mean that was never the
plan.
You'd be surprised to learn just how many
movies could have turned out completely different
if their original twists made it to the finished
film.
Here are Screenrant's 10 Amazing Movie Twists
You've Never Seen.
Lord of the Rings: Return of the King (New
Line Cinema)
The hours of extra footage released in the
Lord of the Rings Extended Editions show that
plenty of key scenes had to be cut before
release, but one scene in the final movie
seems too incredible to have left out.
When Aragorn and his assemble outside the
Black Gate for one last battle, the original
version of the scene saw Sauron himself take
a physical form, and fight the new king.
It was an amazing twist, and in the end, too
amazing, since it made Frodo and Sam's ring
drama seem less important.
Sauron was replaced by a massive troll instead.
The Avengers: Age of Ultron (Marvel/Disney)
The second team up of Marvel's biggest stars
ended on a bittersweet note, with speedster
Quicksilver dead, and a batch of new heroes
set to become the *New* Avengers.
But the hero's death wasn't always a sure
thing: director Joss Whedon admitted that
the final scene was filmed with Quicksilver
included, in a new costume to boot.
To add insult to injury, Marvel taking longer
than expected to get a new Spider-Man and
Captain Marvel off the ground meant Whedon
couldn't include them in the closing scene,
as he'd planned.
Spider-Man would have had fans cheering, but
Whedon thought it would just be funny to include
Captain Marvel without any explanation.
In the end, the bombshell, and the joke, were
nowhere to be found.
World War Z (Paramount)
Seeing Brad Pitt battle zombies in a blockbuster
movie seemed like a dream come true, but his
character Gerry's story didn't always end
so happily.
Instead of a third act that saw Gerry discover
how to solve the zombie crisis, and return
back safely to his family, the original ending
told a completely different story.
Gerry's plane would have landed in Moscow,
where he was forced to join a zombie death
squad for months, eventually taking part in
a massive battle in Red Square.
And why did Lost Star Matthew Fox play such
a tiny role?
He had claimed Gerry's family as his own,
driving the lost father and husband to cross
an ocean back to America, storming the beach
in a storm of zombie carnage.
Then the credits rolled, setting up an even
more intense sequel.
Oh well.
Happy endings are fun too.
Alien (20th Century Fox)
With Ridley Scott's alien horror, Hollywood
didn't just get one its most successful movie
monsters, but one of its greatest sci-fi icons,
and a badass woman for the ages.
But it wasn't always going to play out that
way.
The original script ended with more horror
than victory, with Ripley being ambushed by
the Xenomorph, biting her head clean off before
sending a message to Earth using her own voice.
It's definitely a creepy ending and a shocking
twist, but considering the franchise that
developed around Ripley, it was probably the
way to go.
Rocky Balboa (MGM/Columbia)
Sylvester Stallone blurred the line between
fiction and reality with the 2006 return to
the role of Rocky, playing an old champion
whose best days are behind him, but refuses
to be forgotten.
The movie sent a good message though, since
Rocky proved that youth isn't everything,
losing to a younger, faster boxer, but not
really caring since he put up a good fight.
If that sounds cheesy to you, the original
ending actually had Rocky win the fight, and
remaining as potent a fighter at an old age
as he was in his prime.
In the end, they decided to keep it at least
somewhat believable.
Se7en (New Line Cinema)
Sometimes, it's the idea of a studio NOT going
with a twist ending that seems insane in hindsight.
In the case of the dark serial killer thriller
Seven, director David Fincher and star Brad
Pitt were set on keeping the movie's "what's
in the box" ending, no matter how hard the
studio pushed.
The serial killer John Doe pushing Pitt’s
character to kill him meant the villain won,
with an innocent woman killed in the process.
The studio tried to come up with a different
ending, from having the plan foiled to it
only be a dog's head in the box.
But the strangest idea was to have Morgan
Freeman's soon-to-be-retiring cop gun down
the killer instead, sacrificing his own freedom
just to keep evil from winning the day.
Fincher stuck to his guns, and the darkest,
and most disturbing ending possible guaranteed
the movie's place in Noir history.
Terminator Salvation (Warner Bros.)
It's no secret that more Terminator sequels
have been disappointing than cult classics,
but the original version of Terminator Salvation
at least wanted to try something interesting.
In the finished movie, John Connor's heart
was injured in a battle with a T-800, so a
Terminator/Human hybrid named Marcus sacrificed
his own to keep the resistance leader alive.
But the original ending had Connor die, and
his inner circle decide to attach his face
to Marcus, letting the Terminator lead humanity
to victory in disguise.
If that wasn't dark enough, the director claimed
that HIS ending would have seen the operation
succeed.... before Marcus murdered everybody.
So Salvation could've been a lot worse.
Superman II (Warner Bros.)
When Man of Steel ended with the controversial
death of General Zod, and some fans claimed
that showing Superman commit murder was heresy,
their opponents pointed to Superman 2.
The movie where Superman stripped Zod and
his partners of their powers, then beat them
to a pulp and watched them fall to their deaths.
It's a fair defence of Zack Snyder's reboot,
but the original cut of the movie showed the
Kryptonians didn't die after all.
Instead they were arrested by - we're not
joking - Arctic police.
The trip wound up serving hard time for their
crimes, which means the Man of Steel debate
will probably never end.
Dawn of the Planet of The Apes (20th Century
Fox)
The second film in the rebooted Planet of
the Apes series took audiences by storm, with
most of the credit given to the cast underneath
the cg makeup of the Apes.
But the original ending of the movie set the
stage for an even bigger thriller.
When the human forces are dealt with, the
apes' leader Caesar learns that reinforcements
are already in the way.
The final shot shows Caesar's eyes preparing
for the war ahead, but the movie was originally
planned to show the Navy arriving, and the
Apes squaring off on the Golden Gate bridge.
It achieved the same goal, but the director
thought it only tied his hands for any sequel.
Hancock (Columbia Pictures)
Will Smith's turn as a super powered super
slacker was a strange mix of action, comedy,
superhero origin and mythical love story - but
while the original script and the finished
movie were pretty weird, it almost went to
a very, very dark place.
Instead of learning that his friend's wife
was his super powered soul mate (Charlize
Theron clips from movie's second half), the
original script had Hancock kidnap and try
to force himself on her before slaughtering
the horde of police officers who arrive to
rescue her.
Just to guarantee audiences left the theatre
with their jaws dropped, he would then try
to kill himself with one of the cop's guns.
The bullet didn't leave a mark, but it shocked
the studio into changing the film's direction
completely.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your favorite twist endings
or game-changing deleted scenes in hit movies?
Be sure to share them in the comments, and
subscribe to our channel for more videos like
this one!